61 percent majority that was given to
the no would give the exact you know the
perfect pretext for the Europeans to
actually say you voted yourself against
Europe no matter what the interpretation
is outcome of the referendum is pretty
irrelevant in the sense they're relevant
irrelevant in the sense that Greece face
is the same options today as yesterday
even reform and put its public finances
in order or leave the eurozone it's a
German led decision they suggested it's
in the Greek hands but I think it's in
the German hands and to the extent that
the Germans are unwilling to come off of
their position and to extend their
marginal line I think a grexit is a
seventy to eighty percent probability
probably to exit the EU is the best
option because if they kick if they
default on everything then they'll be
basically dead free here in Greece we
have a protracted disaster going on for
five years and the grexit has been in a
thoroughly digested by the markets and
we have seen that the markets are not
reacting at all to the worst possible
news in fact bad news is good news for
the market as people expect drag you to
come in and throw in some more trillions
so I think it's a day where all our
investors should start thinking long
Greece the fact that he sacked mr.
varoufakis only hours after his victory
says something the fact that he came to
the Greek public and he says I don't
have a mandate for a rupture with Europe
if we continue down this road it is a
road that leads us to Greg alert if that
happens then you should expect a spike
in global risk aversion and then you
will get a sell-off in virtually all
markets at that point good opportunities
are going to be created